executive so if we just go through the
agenda in terms of attendances I think
everyone is here other than James Wright
who is going to be joining us a bit
later or as soon as he can um if we move
to item two which is Declarations of
Interest which I've received none so if
anyone wishes to declare anything do so
now yes no um moving on to item three
then which is questions from the public
and I believe that we've received 10
questions from Mr Chris boys today um
I'm conscious that we've only got 15
minutes as a window for this so we'll
try our best to answer the questions as
we can but it may be if we run out of
time and Alex will indicate the time um
towards the end of the 50 minutes we'll
have to take them away and put them in
writing but as ever I am now going to
hand over to Emma for question
one thank you chair the first question
is in relation
to Rel to the music service and the CL
center with reference to paragraphs 2.7
and the first line of paragraph 3.3
please C the appropriate executive
member give an indication of actual time
scale in this instance associated with
each of the terminologies short medium
and long
term
um was that on yeah these questions came
in quite the the sort of last minute
really so there's been a lot of pressure
on officers today to to pull the anwers
together I've received um answers to
them in a number of emails today so bear
with me as I I go through
um and some of the answers are quite
short um and if further information is
required I'm happy to provide it and
answer to that question we would only
invest in the building if Trafford music
service are going to remain in situe for
a period of five years this is the short
and medium-term Horizon we would then
look at a long-term solution Beyond this
which would be so subject to business
case and
funding okay thank you for that move on
to question two thank you the remainder
of the questions relate to the sa mall
and hail Place plans so with reference
to page 24 of the agenda pack and the
first bullet point of paragraph 4.5
please could you advise the date time
invitees and attendance of the ward
member
briefing
uh in in response uh 16th of September
22 was we held a ward member briefing in
person at Trafford Town Hall uh 20th of
April uh 2023 we had an online session
uh with with Ward members and uh the
12th of September 2023 had online
briefing um yeah that's my
answer question number three uh with
reference to page 9 4 of the agenda pack
the third paragraph makes reference to a
thriving urban center please could an
explanation be given as to what can be
described as an urban center of a
village a defined Center within an urban
area providing a range of commercial and
Community uses to meet local residents
day-to-day
needs question number four references
page 100 of the agenda pack uh with
reference to key stakeholder engagement
please could you give specific details
of the consultation with the friends of
more Nook Park the invitation to the
public cons consultation event was
issued to key stakeholders including the
friends of mup Park both at the time of
the original process and again in
January
2023 question number five references
page
134 uh and refers to two sentences I
will read those out the First on street
parking relocated to accommodate
bidirectional cycle Lane better signage
of Village car parks to encourage use uh
the second on street parking throughout
the village to remain at the same level
with more parking in the heart of the
village for businesses and the question
is please could a clear explanation be
given as to why these two statements are
not
contradictory the intention is to ensure
that the overarching parking level is
not reduced Ed within the center as a
whole what is shown on the strategy is
one One Way by which this could be
achieved whilst providing for the new
layout but as it is set out in the plan
itself a detailed design process is
required to understand Junction capacity
and design parking implications and
wider Road Safety
matters question number six relates to
page
138 and asks with reference to the noted
circle of poten Junction congestion
adjacent to the JW church building has
consideration been given to this being
in the form of a roundabout and if so to
what conclusion and if not why
not any traffic and pedestrian surveys
would be undertaken as
part sorry confused me answer sorry any
traffic and pedestrian surveys would be
undertaken as part of further stages in
being able to deliver elements of the
plan which would be subject to external
funding I part of the detailed design
stages question seven please could there
be a comment as to whether consideration
has been given to the installation of a
light controled pedestrian Crossing at
the junction of northerden Road hampson
Street far better to control the flow of
traffic than at present with a simple
zebra
Crossing full consideration would be
given to all options when drawing up the
detailed design
strategy sorry I just need to clarify I
think I I think I don't know if if you
skipped a question or I have um the
answer to the last one about the
roundabout potential um I will just
answer again as above full consideration
will be given to all options when
drawing up the detail design strategy
for the redesign of the gy Tre if that
was deemed practical deliverable and
funding was available if a roundabout
was considered to be a suitable solution
for this part of the highways Network
taking account of safety and wider
design matters then this could be
included as part of the final design
option would you like me to repeat
question number
seven please could there be a comment as
to whether consideration has been given
to the installation of a light control
pedestrian Crossing at the Junction of
northerden Road hampson Street far
better to control the flow of traffic
than at present with a simple zebra
Crossing full consideration would be
given to all options when drawing up the
detailed design
strategy question number eight given
that Nexus did not consult the council's
records of the original implementation
of the gyratory system and the reasons
for it please could the executive member
confirm whether or not they Nexus have
now done so in relation to the
preparation of this latest iteration of
the
plan um see my previous answers given um
regarding the wider issue on the gyory
Nexus has built on the work already
undertaken by traffic Council and Amy in
respect of the redesign of the gyory
within salmore an understanding of the
reasonings behind its original
implementation and how it functions
today has all been part of the process
in developing the strategy
thank you question number nine please
could you advise whether Nexus have
eventually carried out a traffic survey
to determine the number of users of
their vehicular Journeys through the
various routes to from and most
particularly through sail mall and
assuming that they have please could the
results be published traffic surveys
were not undertaken since any traffic
and pedestrian surveys would be
undertaken as part of any detailed
design works if elements of the plan
were delivered subject to to securing ex
external
funding and the final question question
number 10 references page 135 and asks
with reference to the plan and the
enhanced Crossing on marsland Road close
to its Junction with Conway Road from
the traffic survey what are the
anticipated combined numbers of vehicles
Eastbound and Westbound that will pass
through this Crossing at the busiest
times of the day school run rush hours
Etc if no traffic survey has been
completed what are the estimated
numbers any traffic and pedestrian
surveys will be undertaken as part of
further stages in being able to deliver
elements of the plan which will be
subject to securing external funding I.E
as part of the detailed design stages
and I think I'll I'll cover that later
in my presentation of of the report um
Chris boy here um has in my view asked
more questions of me this evening than
he did um on this plan when he was a a
counselor but that you know the valid
points there and they um are all subject
to you know all the work around the gyat
Tre um and the impact that that has on
The Wider uh Highway Network all subject
to um future um highways and traffic
modeling um should we secure and funding
to carry out this
work thank you very much councelor Patel
for answering all those questions and
thank you to Ema for asking all those
questions and thank you to Chris boy for
sending them in okay we'll move on now
to the next item uh which is Matters
from Council or overview and scrutiny
committee I don't see councilor Acton or
councilor West in the room so councelor
B do you have anything from the health
scrutiny
committee no chair not nothing in
further since the last council meeting
thank you thank you very much for that
so moving say that we've got a meeting
on coming Wednesday that's all thank you
very much okay we'll move on to item
five which is delegated approval to
award part in enforcement the parking
enforcement contract and I understand
councelor Patel that's in your
name thank you leader this report seeks
approval to award a new contract for
parking enforcement and ancillary
services and ask to provide delegate
authority to myself and the director of
place to agree the final terms of the
contract with the winning bidder our
current contract expires at the end of
March 2024 our current Arrangements have
been extended by one year so that we can
coordinate entering a new contract with
Partners at Stockport Bolton and tamide
this process this procurement process is
being managed by star procurement and
represents an example of local Authority
partnership working to secure best value
through economies of scale and access to
a trained secure and flexible Workforce
we've been working closely with these
other authorities to determine a
contract specification and pricing
schedule that will that will ensure we
continue to deliver quality Services
which Embraces new technology and
smarter ways of deployment and ticketing
tender submission uh is by the 29th of
November and bids will be evaluated
during December with final approval
expected in January thank you thank you
very much Council Patel are there any
questions from members of the
executive no any wider questions um
councilor
Welton thank you leader um yeah just U
looking at
1.2 um in the report it says any
potential cost increases can be managed
by reducing the hours of operation um uh
the operation of enforcement this
balance of cost versus successful
enforcement can be managed throughout
the period of the
contract I just wonder if residents
would be surprised to learn that parking
enforcement officers face having that
hours cut if they successfully reduce
the earnings from illegal parking um or
get paid properly for it um seems to me
that that calculation doesn't take into
account The Wider cost of illegal
parking in terms of increased Road
danger particularly around schools and
the significant impact illegal parking
has on those with mobility issues so
I've got two questions firstly why
aren't we allowing for sufficient
sufficient enforcement to actually
eliminate the problem of illegal parking
and balancing that cost from other
sources of parking re Revenue I mean
wouldn't permit holders be reassured to
know that they're actually paying for
the job to be done properly rather than
half done um and secondly when the
contract came before executive
previously I think it was earlier this
year there was reference to cutting the
time warten wardens had to wait before
issuing a ticket down to one minute
where the illegal parking was causing an
obvious danger and I want to know if if
that's still being considered and is
there any reason why that can't be done
immediately thank you okay thank you
councelor Welton councelor Patel thank
you um
I think you slightly sort of
misunderstood um the point around uh
Workforce flexibilities and the income
that that's drawn um everyone employed
within the parking enforcements um will
have a well paid and secured role the
flexibilities come from drawing on a
wider pool of um staff to um when we
need extra support around events um and
so people won't do themselves out of a
of a job by um properly enforcing um
traffic um in Trafford um the one minute
um reduction I'm afraid I don't know um
I will ask Richard but if not we'll
definitely come back to
you yeah we'll come back to that's a
policy choice for the executive uh quite
clearly which was discussed previously
at the moment we're focusing on the
award of the contract things like time
limits and that can be amended within
the contract that's a policy choice
okay thank you councelor Patel thank you
Richard uh councelor
but sorry Council but the lights gone
out onor sorry it's a it's a 10-year
contract and it's 5 plus two plus two
plus one I just in terms of you know
reviewing it just wondering how that
calculate that how do it sort benefit in
certain Cel want to go first yeah I mean
I think that's quite a standard contract
length but it gives us an opportunity to
review it at a certain point and if it's
not working or we need to improve it we
we can do um so that's what that
flexibility um allows
for okay thank you for that any other
questions okay well the recommendations
are one to three as set out in the
report all those in
favor thank you very much okay if we
move on now to item six which is the
Claremont center Chapel Road update and
I believe councilor Patel you're
introducing this paper as
well thank you uh back in January of
2022 uh this exec approved a feasibility
study to facilitate a proposed
Redevelopment of the Claremont Center in
Chapel Street site today I would like to
present an update on this um this work
and seek approval to move forward on a
change proposal to undertake um detailed
planning and commission Works to a
specific scheme on Chapel Street as set
out in the report we have considered a
move for traffic music service to the
stretford library site and then
facilitating a move for that Library
service to stretford town center and the
subsequent Redevelopment of The Wider
Chapel Chapel Road and clont Center
during the feasibility work it has been
identified that the existing condition
of stretford library and options and
limited options to convert the space um
to suit a growing music surface would
not allow for this to go ahead increased
building costs and further constraints
around the conversion of the Claremont
center to residential has further
limited this options this has also been
compounded by uh Rising building costs
inflation and interest rates in February
20 23 we have secured further funding
from the investment management board to
look specifically at just the Chapel
Road Site which is formally used which
was a set of buildings forly used by the
NHS Mental Health Services and are
presenting a revised proposal here
tonight to develop for sale at market
value five Residential Properties some
of the proceeds from this development
will be dedicated to providing
additional storage and backlog maint
addressing the backlog of Maintenance
works at the Claremont center which will
facilitate the stay of Trafford music
service for the medium term of
approximately 5 years a brief update on
stretford Library service work U
continues with the support of the GM
Evergreen Grant to consider options to
re relocate the library into the
Redevelopment of stretford mall and a
condition survey of the existing Library
options on on the future of a stretford
library service and where it will be
located will be reported back to the
executive in due course thank you
thank you councelor Patel are there any
questions from members of the executive
councilor ad
said just a quick comment later just a
ofv Str Li there obviously uh not in
there obvious that it's not suitable for
the Music Center to move in there and
obviously we have to look at again at
the future of potential for that for the
uh Li to move into the Malon uh I'm not
unhappy with that position because
obviously want to make sure we get this
right I do know in places like voling
room uh andon where our library has
moved into the Town Center area which
proved very very successful there so I
think it's certain an option that that
we need to keep uh certainly in our
minds at this point anyway I know we
look at the options in due course I
generally welcome the report I think
it's a it's a lot of information there
and obviously there's a lot more to come
on out for see in a future report on
actual proposals around this thank
you thank you councilor I said I concur
with you regarding stretford Library we
need to make sure I see C slat is also
nodding as well um we need to make sure
we get the proposition right where it's
worked in Ultram we you know would' love
to see something similar in Stratford
and likewise we need to make sure we get
the proposition in the long term for the
music service right as well which is
obviously very important to this
Administration are there any other
questions from the executive okay I'll
go to councilor Evans
then thank you chair um I've got think
three possibly four questions uh so just
confirmation really on what uh short to
medium term I think the executive member
in answering one of EX councel Bo's
questions that suggests five years um
how much of the funding from the sale of
the buildings the new new houses is
likely to go into the building and
Clarance center it's definitely
recognized that it needs needs some work
um and if five years could be extended
to a well at best 25 years but
considerably longer uh travel m m music
service might be in a better position in
the same way the football clubs might be
in a I do appreciate you have to perhaps
change the structure of it but it could
SE seek outside funding it has been
particularly successful the waiting I I
know from residents the waiting list is
horrendous and actually the clar center
is an ideal location sale is an ideal
location equidistant from from stretford
and the north of the B and equidistant
from from my w so um could could some
consideration be given to the extension
Beyond 5 years and actually we've been
looking for a place for 10 years now and
we can't find one so you know we've not
got a bad location there H I know it has
its constraints but with some investment
H maybe we could solve that problem um
and then that suppose that leads on to
why is it an un unsuitable location
which is in the report suggested it is
an unsuitable location thank
you okay thank you very much councelor
Evans if I go to Liz first and I might
defer to Sarah imp Poss Richard as well
because touches different directorates
so Council Patel first yeah I mean as um
identifi before five years is is is the
sort of short to medium term we see
there um I haven't got the actual
figures in front of me but if we're
building five houses I think the the the
value the return of one of those will be
reinvested into um the clont center for
um storage works preliminarily but there
are you know there are some M A backlog
of maintenance there um when we consider
the future location of the music service
um which is growing and could grow um
even more um which is why we initially
considered the the the stretford library
site to grow that that Financial base of
the service um and we certainly would be
interested in um you know exploring
external funding for that um and it
might be that you know in five years
time we're in a position to invest
what's needed into the Claremont center
to make it um you know a long-term prosp
ECT but you know it's a Victorian
building um uh which is restricted in
planning terms um
and if you've ever seen what they need
to store in terms of the musical
instruments you'll understand that
actually it might just be a question of
space um uh but it's it's not off it's
not off the cards it's just something
that perhaps you know we will explore um
moving forward but I don't if anyone
wants to add to it thank you Council
Council
Hines actually councelor Patel made the
point that I was going to make um I
think the important thing to stress here
as well Is our commitment to the music
service as well and making sure that
they are in um the right facility for
them um and as councilor Patel has said
in five years times we might be in a
position to um to invest what is needed
on that site or we might be in a
position to look um for somewhere else
but the commitment absolutely is there
to the music
service lovely I should uh remind people
because I've not done this there is a
part two item to this as well so I think
people have skillfully acknowledge that
themselves so far um now if I go to
councelor Welton for the next question
thank you I think the concern that's
been expressed to me by the music
service is that the um and it was
referred to by councelor evence is is
going to be the problem of getting grant
funding in the in the short to medium
term um because they don't have
a a long lease um and particularly for
the friends of the music service you
know who are obviously s of the
charitable arm of it I guess um you know
they they will be constrained in in what
they can do and who they can get funding
from if we don't have that continuity um
they seem to think that that the music
service is uh you know they would like
to try and create seem to want to create
a future there I understand that there
are limitations you know in terms of we
the waiting list is it may be partly con
constrained by the um by the room size
um but there is the potential to put on
activities you know some of the
activities elsewhere presumably
um we have you know other buildings in
the area that belong belong to the
council that could be used perhaps um so
I don't really understand why we
couldn't kind of go in for a long lease
um now and then I mean does that lease
have to be stuck to in the long term you
know we do find another option in five
or 10 years time but why can't we give a
long lease now so that they have at
least some security and and can actually
make the grant applications that they
they want
to thank you for those questions Council
welon um Council tell should I go to you
first yeah I mean it it would just be to
sort of my comment would be to reassure
um that we are you know committed to the
the music service and supporting it and
and and having it grow um you know the
has been some questions over the
Claremont center which probably leads
back to why there isn't that that that
lease arrangement in place but um I
would welcome um if Richard has any um
background on
that um I think as Council ens said
we've been looking for a solution for
traffic music service for 10 years uh
the move into the Claremont center can't
remember how many years ago was an
interim solution at that point pending
finding somewhere that was super suble
in terms of size parking facilities for
concerts storage forment and everything
else so I think if the what we're saying
now is we want to deal with the
immediate issues that we need to do with
the condition of the building at the Kon
Center there are works that needs to be
done this is a way that we raise some
Finance for in order in order for us to
do that if there's funding Parts out
there that we can secure that meets the
needs of the music service and the
council then there's absolutely no doubt
that uh we will we can look at a longer
leak we're not ruling that out I think
it's been made clear proposed by Council
Kel the leader and the deputy leader it
is let's deal with the immediate issues
that we need to do there in terms of the
the property comp condition we looked at
stretford library we've looked at doing
new bills we've looked at various
options over the last uh 10 years if the
clayon center is the right answer then I
think there is a commitment to that we
just want to make sure that it is the
right
answer thank you Richard were there any
other questions uh councelor
but just uh you know regarding the
proposed disposal for Chapel Road uh
which is for the scheme for the five
houses is any way they confirm there
going kind of precondition
or that can be applied that could
provide to any kind of affordable
housing element is there an affordable
housing element within that scheme or
not Council Cel do you want to answer
that um there is no um provision for
affordable housing within the scheme the
five properties will be um sold at
market
value okay well I see no other questions
so the recommendations are one to five
as set out in the report all those in
favor thank you very much and moving on
and this is uh still with councelor
Patel and this is the sale more and hail
Place plans Council if you want to uh
introduce this paper thank
you I'm delighted this evening to be
presenting Place plans for Hail and sa
more Village these plans represent for
both Villages Village centers the first
time in decades if ever that traffi has
taken an in-depth look at how these
places work how people use them their
strengths opportunities and the
challenges they face much of the focus
of planning and regeneration has been on
our town centers this administ
ministration commissioned this work in
support of our smaller but just as
important Village centers both hail and
sail Moore have a unique offer which is
successfully embedded in their local
communities they offer residents local
convenience shopping access to
Independent retailers often not found in
our town centers and a local and growing
Hospitality offer they provide residents
with a chance to connect socially with
friends and family and participate in
local community activity the development
of these plans has been a long and
sometimes difficult process initiated in
2019 we experienced significant delays
to progress caused by the impact of
covid within these four Within These
Place plans four distinct stages are
identified which set out the timetable
of these plans and the consultation
undertaken for those interested in how
we got to this place today these are a
useful summary of The Journey I am
confident that the consultation
undertaken has been appropriate and is
sound it's important to note that these
documents are not adopted planning
policy these are strategic plans which
provide some fundamental principles
designed to attract and focus future
investment these plans establish the
role and function in ha of hail and sale
more Village centers the vision for the
future of them how land could be used
more effectively opportunities for
improvements to accessibility and the
role that different stakeholders can
play in delivering that Vision
critically these plans provide the basis
on which the council can bid for
potential funding not a position we have
been in before I would just like to make
some specific points about the
individual plans The Village plan for
Hail has drawn inspiration from hail's
current strengths and acknowledges where
improvements are possible with three
features guiding the assessment of the
village firstly movement how people
interact and use hail from the
surrounding residential catchments and
further a field secondly public realm
how hail works for pedestrians bicycles
cars and buses and thirdly streetscape
how we can plan for the future of hail
having regard to the overall Aesthetics
which in turn attract new operators and
retain those already present there are
lots of positive stuff identified within
the hail Place plan as a result of that
assessment there is potential to create
space for Community activity to increase
footfall increase dwell time improve
landscaping and Street Furniture with a
focus Around the Clock Tower we could
bring build on the exciting new library
and Bowling Club plans alongside the
crown passages scheme to regenerate the
Bowling Green area encouraging a range
of uses and maximizing the benefits of
the of the to the area of this new
center we looked at the commercial
offering the village and found that
there's a gap been identified for more
familyfriendly Leisure provision we
could support the village to be more
accessible for those who walk currently
57% of people who responded to
consultation walk to the Village we
could improve signage and lighting
investing in the public realm creating
new spaces widening Pavements allowing
further business use of these public
spaces we could improve safety by
reducing the dominance of cars within
the streetcape better linking one end of
the village to the other I would like to
make a point that the availability and
the existing usage of car parking in
hail was quickly identified as a key
issue affecting the development of this
plan and as such we undertook a parking
survey
encompassing on and off street parking
across a village to better understand
the existing situation surveys were
undertaken in 2019 and again in
2023 the findings of this survey are
reported upon in the wsp that's the uh
traffic Consultants technical note
provided as an appendix to the place
plan the results from this survey
demonstrate that even at peak hours on a
Thursday and Friday over 30% of the
surveyed parking stock was available it
is accepted that the majority of this
availability lies away from the
locations directly in the center which
are those popular locations for parking
however the area surveyed all lie within
around 500 meters of the center of the
village and as such it is still
considered possible to park in these
areas and walk to the Village Center for
most
people to S more s more residents are
very proud of their Village and it has a
unique character history and identity
serving a significant walk-in local
community it's home to some anchor
independent retailers that have operated
for decades 61% of the latest survey
respondents arrive on foot though the
village is dominated by highways and
vehicular movement serving in effect as
a route a busy route to the M60 as with
ha this Village sore Village Place plan
has drawn on sail Moore's current
strengths and acknowledges where
improvements are possible again looking
at three features of the village firstly
movement how people interact and use
sail more in the surrounding residential
catchments public realm how salmore
works for pedestrians bicycles cars and
buses and how these linked with the
gyory system within the village and
Street Scapes how we plan for the future
of salmore having regard to overall
Aesthetics which in turn attracts new
operators and retain those already
present we've got some key findings and
opportunities that were identified as a
result of this study significant
opportunities could result from the
slowing down of traffic Improvement of
pedestrian safety and access and
removing Road barriers which look
unsightly and disconnect drivers from
their responsibilities to other Road
users salmore Village Center has a
relatively limited Leisure offer
although that's changing and there is an
opportunity to to improve and divers
diversify The Village Center offer an
increased footfall to the center both in
the day and in the evening widening
Pavements and reducing vehicle speed and
noise will support the extension of this
business activity there is an
opportunity to develop modern business
and retail space and improve the
frontages of new and existing businesses
encouraging independent retailers to
stay and start up we could improve
public Realm by upgrading signage and
removing Street clutter and invest in
Street furniture and Landscaping this
will help support Community activity and
enhance Shopper experience and dwell
time and help improve the image and
marketing of the village as a
destination sign ific remodeling of the
gyory has been presented in the place
plan to reduce the impact of heavy
traffic flow through the Village Center
whilst the majority of respondents to
this consultation were supportive of the
changes proposed this has presented
genuine questions relating to the impact
of these changes on existing and new
Junctions which were not answered
through this master planning work it is
acknowledged that this would require
further detailed highways and traffic
modeling both plans contain potential
next steps a useful breakdown of the
potential way
forward within their plans there noting
that there is no immediate funding
available to apply
for these next steps include commitments
to monitoring the Vitality of the
village centers to possible public real
projects it is evident that this piece
of work has raised the profile of hail
and sale more and given us a real
Direction in terms of investment for
those who have questions or concerns
about specific proposals please note
that this decision tonight does not Mark
a start on site future interventions are
dependent on securing outside investment
and will be subject to further public
consultation within future plan making
or planning
applications I acknowledge that some
residents and businesses have found some
aspects of the plans challenging the
move from car dominated spaces to one
which still retains on street parking
but at a reduced level is a new approach
these more centralized parking
Arrangements allow for these significant
public round improvements to take place
and there is plenty of evidence that
where this has been done elsewhere
business centers have thrived and using
those examples if and when funding
becomes available I sure we can take
people with us I think what's presented
here tonight is is a really positive
take on the future of hail and S Mo on
one which balances residents needs and
business ambition thank
you thank you very much councilor Patel
for a comprehensive walk through the uh
the papers there I'm really pleased to
see the uh Place plans come to us this
evening I think it provides a framework
for both those areas as someone who
lived in salmore for almost seven years
going back a few years now it's good to
see some attention U being being being
set for that area it is a you know a
bustling bustling place and there's a
lot more potential there for us things
like Place plan plans provide that
framework as you say for future
investment and uh and improvements to
the area um these as the report says are
not inflexible or prescriptive they are
there to try and keep these uh two key
villages in traford thriving so I'm very
much welcome this are there any
questions or comments from the executive
Council
Williams thank you chair um I just
briefly wanted to comment to um welcome
these Place plans coming to Executive
this evening um I grew up in old chingam
and spending the first few years of my
life in hail and when I go back now to
the south of the B to see my family I'm
just so struck at how successful the
Regeneration of ult ringham has been but
I think as part of that what we don't
want to happen is that Hal gets
forgotten onor um isn't considered as
important a part of ult trium as it is
and I can't speak with as much Authority
as you about s more but I know that s
more and joy in Council Council of a
very Fierce of the C indeed and the only
other thing I wanted to reflect upon is
that um these Place PS don't exist in is
ation and this administration's
undertaken a large body of way to
improve our approach and the approach of
the council to play shaping I'm thinking
in particular and today are referred to
um in the supplementary documents of the
recent work that's been undertaken by
the planning department in drafting art
design guide so I hope that these plans
will complement that work and that they
can serve as a f further sort of feather
in art bow enabling us to safeguard and
enhance our village centes and urban
population obv thank you ch
thank you very much councelor
rad just very briefly leader and say
Obviously like to welcome these I can't
say I know them as much as many members
around the room but I have been to B and
love to do frequent sale more a little
bit more as well I think it's a quirky
nature of these small village centers
which have a different completely
different feeli to the town centers I I
live in the town center and and a
completely different way you got big
names got more open shops councel
outline there it's the it's it's the way
the town developed over these have
developed over the years and it's the
old field to a lot of these places as
well it gives it much more personal AG
in the town centers which are big and
Brash and I think something like is it's
important to actually keep those small
retailers there and actually quite
welcome this investment I think it's a
whil over the last several years we've
been looking at a lot of investment in
our town centers I think the time is
definitely right now to look at the
small village centers like the viability
up many of their local communities so I
welcome the report thank you Le yeah
absolutely it's about aining our the
viability of our Villages like hail and
sore um okay are there any further
questions from outside the
executive Council
Evans thank you chair um I've not gotten
awful lot of comments on the the place
plans and one of the reasons I'm not got
too many comments on the place plans I
was led to believe at the consultation
in January that this was going back out
once and effectively the January
consultation was not actually the
consult consult ation it was effectively
reigniting it I remember feeding back to
I guess Nexus I can't remember the
lady's name comments in general um but
was was met with well it's not too
important now because we will be coming
back to this clearly we aren't and the
executive member did complain about
councelor councelor boy's questions
being late coming in this is a massive
report that was late coming in and and
the inclusion of these two Place plans
is a surprise to everybody now it's not
just me that has said we were expecting
certainly the hail well actually I've
got a letter with respect to sale more
oh clearly it's it's less of my area to
be frank um residents in general were
expecting to come back to this um and
look at it we've got resident parking
coming in on 36 Street anytime soon
that's going to affect the whole um
you've got some traffic service but it
certainly can't
that can't be included in it so really
it's it's not so much the content of the
plans but actually the expectation of
the residents um and the stakeholders
that why are we here
today right C Patel there's we set out a
detailed timetable of of consultation
and I I I simply don't recognize that um
that in January um we committed to
further public consultation events that
was never the case um the online um
consultation process was remained open
past that last latest um public
consultation event and and there's a
sort of a meaningful um impact of that
the place plans have changed so I know
that in hail um they made changes they
retained pedestrian crossings they
changed the layout Around the Clock
Tower we changed proposals um to the
Bowling Green um and we renewed the
parking survey um that we were using and
yes um circumstances will always change
and the park residents parking that's
come in will have to be reviewed should
we go ahead with any of this work the
impact of that um um but no
uh no further um commitments um were
made to hold or host um public
consultation events um I I know that
we've had a a a a flurry of of of
contact UM from uh the Civic Society um
and I know that the Federation of small
businesses in in relation to that um I
am as I said at the outset confident
that that we have conducted a fair and
transparent consultation process
everyone who has wanted to contribute
has been given the opportunity to
contribute and the plans have changed as
a result this is a process that's been
going on uh since
2019 and I think it's important in terms
of um moving forward to actually
implementing some of these changes that
we now um come to approve it as a broad
set of principles that will be subject
to much more um public consultation as
in when um new plans are drawn up or
planning applications are
submitted thank you councelor Patel um
councelor
Lester thank you leader and thank you
thank you to all the officers who've
worked on this plan we know it we know
it's com
complicated um the healthplace plan has
been controversial for a long time
really and some people have expressed
anger that there hasn't been enough
consultation and they're expect
questioning the quality of the
consultation and go back to what
councelor Williams said H residents have
felt
forgotten there's a wide range of views
about what would be best for Hail and it
would be impossible to create a document
that satisfies everyone we we we
appreciate we understand that uh we know
that the plan is less than perfect and
it could be far more much more far
reaching the second consultation has
resulted in some of the changes as
councelor Patel has mentioned and I
think that's important to note um but
we're cons we're concerned that if the
place pl's not approved hell will be
left behind the document isn't a
planning policy it's a tool to apply for
funding for improvements for the village
and it will feed into the local plan
we're already seeing the opportunities
are being missed and hail hail is
already falling behind in terms of
access to funding but can you
demonstrate you've referred to this
slightly already but can you demonstrate
that a satisfactory of level level of
consultation has taken place and can you
guarantee that going forwards there will
be consultation and Community
involvement is every step of the way for
the proposed development ensuring that
the plans are the best that they can be
and also that the plan's not set in
stone and can change going
forwards thank you councel Lester
councelor Patel thank you um councelor
Lester um I would like to Echo the the
thanks to officers and to Nexus planning
who have um undertaken this uh it is a
complex piece of work um through which
uh there are many different um opinions
to draw together um we s
uh to the point on hail residents um
certainly not forgotten and hail um you
know this is an Evidence of that hail
Village Center is is important to us as
other Village centers are I know you've
got a um a new library within the the
the village and a new community center a
a a refurbished or it's on its way
ledure Center within very close
proximity um you um benefit residents
benefit from investment into your parks
and Roads um like many um traffic
residents um the the consultation is set
out within the pace plans I said that
it's broken down into four different
stages um uh I'm you know I'm happy to
provide more uh detailed information on
that if required if that's not enough to
um explain the extensive um uh
consultation we sought views from
residents from businesses I know that
every single business in hail and
salmore Village will hand delivered in
this latest round and earlier this year
a letter explaining the proposals and
inviting their comment um uh that many
of them chose not to um uh comment this
is the businesses um you know what can
you read into that um that they're happy
with proposals that they're okay with
them or they're not happy with proposals
um you know you were given an
opportunity to to um make your views
known um nothing is ever set in stone um
you know since we started this piece of
work the design codes come along uh
streets for all has come along um new
transport Arrangements have come along
um you know we we work within an
everchanging envir environment um and
but one thing is for certain um in both
those Village centers that um that there
there is a sort of um perhaps a a
difference between how residents and
businesses feel about um on street
parking and and the need for it and I
think we need to moving forward make
sure that we try and uh bridge that um
bridge that Gap and not try and exploit
it um you know businesses uh require the
confidence to know that investment into
the public realm and um giving people an
opportunity to walk more safely and stay
longer in a Village Center is a is a
benefit to them as a business and that's
evidenced in many places where this um
where this type of work has been
undertaken so nothing is set in stone
and everything that comes forward will
require um a future public consultation
so perhaps to um councilor evanson's
point before that's what the the future
consultation commitment was it wasn't
through this process necessarily it was
was as and when these sort of projects
come forward out of it thank you Council
pel Council and the
pory thank you leader uh we welcome both
of these plans and I welcome council ad
head's comments about small village
centers
um we would like to know when timley is
going to have its own plan drawn up we
know that there are huge financial
challenges facing Trafford and we know
that regeneration is hard to fund in the
current landscape but we note the
interesting change in from the
government who use conferences and to
start talking about leveling up small
towns Villages um we want to see plans
drawn up for templey that look at
maximizing the potential of the Village
Center as a destination so that should a
future government decide to make Town
Center Village Center regen funding
available templey has a plan ready and
waiting very pleased to see local plans
start to come to fruition across the
burrow but templey deserves a fair deal
too
thank you thank you councelor laori uh
councilor forel your right to advocate
for timly um you know uh there isn't
currently any um leveling up monies
available to um direct it at our Village
um centers um I can't uh offer a
commitment here but certainly you know
as a as an Administration we would
certainly look to to to to provide this
sort of Master planning in in every um
locality I know that um councilors in
Ashton um have been asking the same
thing so perhaps that is the next stage
but um perhaps we'll do them separately
and not not not join up Ashton and
Temple one piece of work thank you
Council Patel and a former resident of
timley as well I also value the
importance of timley as well as s Mo and
ha of course have not lived there um
council suton did you indicate your ask
a question uh yes thank you um just
echoing the thanks to the officers
involved but uh also wanted to
acknowledge uh all of the other people
who contributed to this plan uh
including uh all of the stakeholder
input residents input uh and that of
previous counselors because of the the
length of time this has uh been uh uh
underway um I came to it relatively
recently in in an official capacity but
I've been uh well aware of what's been
happening uh since although since 2019
and pleased that there is now some uh
progress in sight um plan such of this
will never find full agreement between
everybody uh it's safe to say that if I
was drawing this up unilaterally it
would look quite different um but there
has been so much input from all
different viewpoints we it definitely is
time to move forward um I wanted to give
credit to Nexus staff as well who um
after I was elected in May I found to be
very approachable and open uh when it
came to discussing the plans and the
backgrounds to how they've been
developed for hell Village to thrive uh
it needs people out on the street and in
shops and restaurants and other
businesses businesses not inside
vehicles um the listed carbon reduction
benefit to reduce vehicle Reliance uh
and also in counc pel's introduction the
general aim of reducing vehicle
dominance doesn't really marry up uh
with aspects of the place plans such as
no real aim to reduce or eliminate uh
volume traffic using asro as a through
route um nor does the retention of the
existing overall number of parking
spaces make much sense against this
desire to reduce vehicle dominance
uh or against the data which shows
parking spaces sit on used for a large
periods of time and that and that the
majority of people accessing the village
already do not travel by car um so I'd
like to ask uh whether the council will
commit to working with counselors and
residents uh to develop shortterm but
important aspects of these plans ones
which are within the gift of a council
under economic challenges uh for example
20 mph limits on Ashley Road and
surrounding streets working
collaboratively alongside residents and
outside specialist organizations to
improve accessibility such as for people
with impaired mobility user Mobility
AIDS and those with sensory disabilities
and particularly bearing in mind that
the council has adopted of its Invision
zero Target what processes will be in
place to ensure that all improvements to
to uh to H vill are individually
assessed for whether they will play a
part in meeting that
Target thank you uh councelor
Patel um thank you uh for those comments
and again thank you for your
acknowledgement of the hard work of of
Nexus planning and um residents and
stakeholders who've taken their time
over two separate ways of consultation
to make their views known um I think you
know you raised some some valid points
around um parking um and vehicular
movement and you
know some people would want us to go
further and some people think we've gone
too far so there's always a balance and
as we move forward we'll make those
decisions based on the the latest
evidence um and best practice available
to us um there is a a table of sort of
next steps um potentially that we could
look at within this plan in hail um
which commits to um some public ground
works and um ongoing monitoring of the
health of the center um signage and
legibility strategy and certainly um
disability access and improving that in
our town and Village centers is a key
ambition of of of this Administration um
obviously all funding dependent um 20
miles an hour that specific um uh ask
hasn't been ident or wasn't identified
within this um plan and I know you know
the green party has been a a fierce
advocate for that in the burough and we
have answered that on a number of
occasions that that you know uh we we
will consider it um you know it would
make a difference um you know slowing
down traffic through our village centers
the speed and the volume of traffic
through both hail and sail War um uh
really to the detriment of the
experience of visiting those places um
so I'm afraid I can't give you a
commitment here on the 20 M hour but
we'll look into it um and on the other
things um yes um you know this is the
Catalyst for looking at those
interventions and securing that funding
um moving forward so yeah we'll work
we'll work with local counselors on
that thank you very much councelor Patel
I don't see any other hands raised so
what we're looking at here are two high
level documents that provide vision for
both hail and for sa Village and and
they can be used to guide future
activities and potential funding bid so
I'm happy to ask you to approve all
those in
favor thank you and thank you councelor
Patel for your hard work this evening
we're now going to move on to the budget
monitoring report period six and I will
now pass over to councelor
Harding thank you leader um I present
this evening's uh period six outturn
report which is a report for noting um
again just to um give credit really to
offices in the way this report has been
um outlined in a much more comprehensive
and easy to digest um format part one
the high level summary part two the
narrative and part three goes into the
annexes go into very specific detail
around each element of the budget um the
as I said the report is for
noting and um so note the report and the
estimated revenue outturn and note that
there are some positive movements in the
estimated outturn since period four that
said it is important to recognize the
scale of the challenge that we face um
as I went into great detail in the draft
budget report we have a huge challenge
ahead of us the report outlines those
areas where we are still facing
considerable challenges such as
children's though there have been some
improvements in the movement around
children's placements work continues to
be done in this area the home to home to
school transport and the dedicated
schools Grant are the areas that we
continue to Monitor and um do do work on
just in the report the recommendations
are then note the report and the
estimated Revenue outter position note
the update of the capital program with a
more detailed report coming in February
and note the positive movements I do
want to say just as on page 20 of the
report 2.7 the scale of the challenged
faced means that the council must
continue to identify significant
permanent savings Lobby the government
to address the unfairness of the funding
formula and maintain prudent financial
management I'm sure we will all have
expressed disappointment at the lack of
anything for local government in the
Autumn statement
um and we don't know what awaits us for
the December settlement so the report is
for noting thank you to all the officers
who continue to work really hard to make
sure we manage the scale of the
challenge thank you leader thank you
councelor Harding indeed it is a
positive movement um compared with
period four but we are still noting an
overspend of half million pounds and we
we must must keep focus on bringing it
into balance as I know that you and
officers are doing because that will
mean that it it helps us in the
situation next year but having said that
I also note with disappointment the fact
that local government uh social care
were not mentioned as part of the Autumn
statement last week and I know that
several Council leaders across the
country are very concerned about the
support that's not forthcoming so far
from the government are there any
questions from members of the
executive any wider
questions uh councelor Welton first of
all thanks uh just specifically on the
lower than expected uh revenue from
planning application um fees I was just
wondering is is that because fewer
applications are being made or or
because we're struggling to process them
and um do we know as yet what the impact
is likely to be of being able to charge
for the full cost of um processing the
applications that seem to be outlined in
the Autumn statements thank
you thank you councilor Welton I'm going
toer to Richard on that one
thing thank you Council and thank you
councel welon for the question um the
lower than expected level of planning
fee income is because of a reduction in
planning applications in particular
major planning applications which is
probably not uh to be surprised given
some of the current economic uh
uncertainty we are working through the
implications of the uh increasing
planning fees which will be coming in on
the 6th of uh December and it will
clearly in part be dependent on the
number of applications that we get uh in
future um our assessment is the moment
it will cover some of the sh but no not
necessarily get us back to the budget
position that we expected at the start
of the year but we will need to work
that through the the year into the next
finan thank you uh councilor but thank
you chair I've got six questions I to
take them separately or easy if I take
them
separately yeah yeah separately fine
because it's Financial so yeah uh the
one the first one is on council tax par
17 for I'm just asking what the value of
the government grant was that covered
the council tax support scheme which
cost the council I think 340,000
okay Council Harding gra do you want to
take that
first councilor book we'll get back to
with the response on that that's okay
okay thank you I've noted the question
and we I'll make sure you email tomorrow
okay thank you and Page 175 there was
delay obviously there's delayed opening
of the Regent sh Road car park in
altringham
which uh is reported to cost the council
229,000 in Lost Revenue so can you tell
us when it's likely to be opened as it
must be having a significant impact on
the local economy of what Alam uh and
obviously on the Council budget I
correcting thank you councelor but I
think we've had this question before it
certainly sounds familiar
um I think Council wel asked us two
weeks ago and I think the answer is we
are we are we are working with the
developer that car park in order to try
and get the car park open as uh soon as
we can we don't have an estimated open
at the moment it's not we I was under
the impression he wasn't really all that
bother about opening because it stopped
the cars
coming anyway um page 30 uh is
government grant uh Services grant for
the 2324 received uh uh was one uh 1.47
million June
23 uh 55k above the budget was that a
block grant or was it against any
specific
needs which part of the report you
referring to coun page
30 page
30 to do with the services Grant
okay
government
grants
specif yes it said that they received a
1.47 million 58,000 above the uh the
budget so I was just wondering what that
what because it was a budget was that
like a block r that youed or was it any
specific
right okay uh and on page 194 the risk
reserve on the risk Reserve chart uh
there risk Reserve is down to 3.83
million because of costs of around one
and a half million against the Town
Center foreign costs and the GMP site
setup costs uh are these costs likely to
be similar or more in the next financial
F 2425 are you looking at something of a
similar kind
of
um
cost looking at projections over the
next couple of
years yeah
yeah is that okay yeah I'm just thinking
know I'm just want that whether that
cost was you're going to get a similar
kind of situation again in the next
following
year yeah
gra if you just put your mic
on I think the two Town Center
regeneration schemes at stretford and
Stanford quarter as you know there quite
significant regeneration Works which are
impacted on some of the income that
we're getting so we probably anticipate
that we are going to have a call off of
that Reserve over the next over the
period of regeneration so it will go
beyond this year certainly but dependent
on one Lord Works last
for right okay that's fine okay thank
you councelor B councel the
pory thank you I'd just like to thank
all the officers I know it's really
difficult at the moment um I'm on
page4 and adult demand um the underspend
of
64,000 and the favorable movement of
494k um my question relates to the
contingency fund um and this comes after
um no new money for social care uh from
the budget or the Autumn statement and
unexpected
um and noting from your LA from the last
meeting the 1.4 million pound reduction
in adult service funding for
Trafford do we think we'll be able to
maintain that
contingency or will that contingency be
shrunk down in order to backfill some of
that 1.4 million pound um drop that
we're having to fund or find something
for and as well has the cost of the
minimum wage and the living wage that's
going up all been factored into that
figure at the moment and in future
figures um and when do we see that
rolling out are we wait until April 1st
or are we going to do it soon
um thank you Council laor I'm going to
take that in two parts I am going to
hand over to Nathan in a minute because
that you specifically asked a question
around adults um I think as I mentioned
when I did the draft executive report
really the scale of the challenge is
huge around those demand Le budgets and
demand is going up not down um we do
have contingency obviously because that
allows us to make sure that we provide
for the most vulnerable people in
Trafford um that trajectory continues to
go up it isn't going down um and as part
of the finance and change board work all
of I think I said last time we're
leaving no stone ont in relation to how
we manage the budget and continue to
make sure that we're not in a position
around a section 114 but I am going to
hand over to Nathan so he can maybe go
into more detail around some of those
contingencies around
adults thanks councelor Hardy and thanks
councelor Cory for the question um in
terms of the contingency funds obviously
that's in place um to mitigate against
any any volatility in in the budget and
is a volatile budget you know we have
people coming in and out of adult social
care um but when they do come in it
obviously comes out a cost in terms of
the um ability to maintain the
contingency funds that is something that
is is Factor within our our budget
planning um but as you will be aware um
when we went through the Council budget
draft proposals um we are having to
review um some of our demographic
pressures monies which obviously relates
to Bing of people coming into
service there will be a
contingency um but we have to be
pragmatic have social care makes up
considerable chunk of the Council budget
and obviously you have to be prudent and
how we spend our money money whilst
being cognizant of our needs to meet the
needs of anybody who requires care and
support in terms of your question about
the living wage and real living wage um
we are in the midst of our
consultation um with providers around
the fee uplifts which will report into
the next um iteration of the draft
budget um we have factored in living
wage um there are challenges around the
real living wage in terms of the
projections which were were given from
the LJ and the actuality of the the
increase um mean there is a little bit
of work to bridge that Gap but we still
remain as a council absolutely committed
to paying the real living wage and we
see that critical in our social care
given the challenges in recruiting to
the
work thank you and councilor Evans as
you indicated earlier
thank you chair it was two questions but
council welon help put the first one on
the planning um page 18 page 166
whichever page you want to take business
rates at 1.8 million uh down try
primarily from the Trafford Center those
stores are not open now uh is it
unlikely to rush them through from
January February March as it's the quiet
time are we anticipating that again I
know we've moved 1.5 million over from
the general Reserve to there is is that
anticipated to continue into the next
period I think Richard is indicating he
can respond so I'll go to
Richard I can in terms of uh
availability space at the trael center
the key one is that you were M and Spen
is either opened or is it's about to
open in the form of deance space that
takes up a significant proportion of EMP
um space which will help both from
business rates perspective on that unit
but also you would expect on business
rates at that end of traffic Cent
because of the footfall that it will
bring down you'd expect to see a benefit
of that for businesses at the other end
we do speak to uh Trafford Center on a
regular basis we meet with them
quarterly they share their plans with us
so we know that they are working plans
on on plans on the space the ma and
Spencers have vacated to move into Deon
they not going to let that sit uh empty
so they are working on plans there to
relate that space and overall they are
seeing their footfall increase year on
year which is
posi
Council thank you right thank you thank
you very much Council Harding and thank
you as ever to our finance team led by
Graham and um recommendations are set
out as a to c in the report all those in
favor okay I'm moving on it's the
treasury management annual performance
report outturn um and councelor Harding
again thank you leader um this is an
incredibly complex and detailed report
and when they say you take when when you
become a counselor you will cover all
kinds of areas well honestly um I never
expected to be figuring treasury
management and accounts Etc however I'm
not minimizing or being flippant on that
because on some recent training from the
LGA it was stressed just how incredibly
important it is that all counselors are
cited on Treasury management accounts
and audit and risk and governance so I
know that this Council has provided some
training on credential indicators for
members and I'm certainly advocating to
make sure that all our counselors have
access to training and asking the right
questions around risk around finances
because it's imperative for counselors
to be cited so that's said that's my
plea for training the report has been
through accounts and audit last
Wednesday the executive summary is
outlined on page 209 of the report
during 2022 and 2023 the council
achieved compliance of its legisl
legislative and regulatory requirements
via the following activities economic
position debt Investments and credential
indicators and I'm delighted to say that
no breaches have occurred
so that said um the report is for noting
I think I just wanted to reference
something on page 220 here it is the
reasons for recommendation this report
is a mandatory report which has been
produced in order to comply with the re
requirements of the council's financial
procedure rules which incorporate the
requirements of both the SI for
credential code for Capital Finance and
the Sia code of practice on Treasury
management thank you leader thank you
councelor Harding are there any
questions from the executive any further
questions councelor
Welton thank you uh leader and thank you
councelor Harding and as recently as
I've recently joined the council audit
um I know the pain of having to learn
all this stuff and I can't say that I'm
I I I'm completely across it yet but
it's certainly certainly in incredibly
enlightening um
one thing that that strikes strikes me
as a beginner shall we say um the big
long list of places where we do invest
our money put our deposits um on page
224 is very interesting to look at um
and it would probably surprise many
Trafford residents to know that we have
such huge deposits with very far-flung
Banks including two associated with
Middle Eastern Petro States um and I'm
just wondering what we know about the
use to which that money is put by those
Banks is there are there any ethical
firewalls or anything like that um I
mean some of it could be going to PL
parts of China that maybe we don't want
to be investing in or investing in
things um that may be actually making
our climate emissions worse um and what
is the opportunity cost for the British
economy of it not being invested with
domestic institutions thank you very
much thank you Council Welton um Council
Harding
Graham um I just wanted to reference a
part of the report that when I read this
earlier on um several times all treasury
management transactions undertaken by
the council are carried out with
institutions with no no no direct links
to any illegal regimes or which promote
the use of forced labor was there
something more specific detail that you
wanted in relation to that councilor
welson because obviously I'm clearly not
going to have the response to that right
here and now but if you are clear with
me I can try and find the answers for
you I'll save that one for next time as
I do my car continue with my Learning
Journey thank you very much thank you
and councilor B not a question as much
as a just a comment there on the summary
box at the beginning of the it external
debt there it says
332.00 is that actually 322
mil which it mentions later
on is that
another so it says 332 on the summary
box at which page did you see the 322
Council the books because I've clarified
that for in the debt Section
Five Section
Five so it says 322 there and this one
says
332 so it looks like
a I think there's two different numbers
there play I think the some RX refers it
does say average doesn't it yeah
a
yeah figure in the
tabl stand
correct no thanks for raising that it's
important to check um any other
questions councilor Evans just just one
and it's really for clarity because I
don't understand the line um page 224
appendix D breakdown of Investments the
bottom one asset investment program 12
million I haven't noted that before
maybe I should have been what is that
line BAS
that line refers to a treasury
investment we made and it was a treasury
investment associated with the Alber
estate in Manchester which is part of
the overall asset investment strategy
portfolio but we did it as a treasury
investment at the time because it fit
the
criteria
yep does that mean that the valuations
within the asset in the invest M
portfolio is I can't find it now because
I looking for is 12 million a drift and
that it seems a an odd thing that we
would if it fit if it fitted the
criteria then clearly we can do it it
just seem odd to have the loan to the
Albert estate sitting in within the
Investment Portfolio and yet the council
outside the Investment Portfolio is
loaning it money it seems odd to do it
that way
I think just to add to that it's just
the way we Finance it
um it's only one investment but we've
we've it's the way we categorized it
we've categorized that as a treasury
investment which is why the probably is
a little bit of overlap and that's what
the difficulty is to some degree around
some of the treasury
Investments um but we did go to council
at the time to get approval to this
investment through to class it as a
treasury invest
could I get the background on that
please I clearly it might have a for but
as as a board member I find that
concerning so thank you yeah we we we'll
get you the uh the background for that
that's absolutely fine okay um so this
is for noting those happy to note thank
you very much okay so we now move on to
item 10 which is council tax reduction
scheme which I will introduce so as
members will be aware the council
administers a council tax reduction
scheme which provides support for
Trafford residents on low incomes to
help out with their council tax bills
approximately 13,000 of our residents
collectively benefit from1 million
pounds of support in January each year
the scheme is reviewed and ultimately
agreed by the executive to coincide with
the production of our annual council tax
bills for the forthcoming Financial year
following the approval of the scheme for
2324 evaluation tribunal made a decision
on the 17th of March 2023 to determine
that the council had not assessed a
claim from a resident on universal
credit with eligible child care costs in
accordance with strict strict wording of
the scheme on the basis of the valuation
tribunal and subsequent wide review it
is accepted that claims made by all
those in receipt of Universal Credit
with eligible child care costs should be
reassessed in accordance with the strict
wording of the scheme a small number of
claimants have been identified as being
potentially being affected uh we're
looking at approximately 100 each year
and a letter will be sent to those
claimants those who think they have been
impacted will have the opportunity to
apply for reassessment of their claim
for the period since April
2017 we will write to all those
claimants in receipt of uniforce versal
credit with eligible child care costs
claims going back to the 2017 2018
Financial year where claimants were
either assessed as being entitled to
receive partial council tax support or
where they were assessed as having a nil
entitlement we will be inviting
applications for reassessments to be
made by midday on Wednesday the 28th of
February
2024 I'm very happy to take questions
now but I'm conscious this is quite a
technical paper so it may not be
possible for me to provide full answers
today in which case we will make sure we
get answers in writing to an on who ask
so are there any questions from members
of the executive first of all any wider
questions councilor Evans thank you
chair um two two questions one clearly
we wrote rewrote this several recently
and I guess we've Rewritten this year on
year for since 2014 is it so question
one is is it that it's morphed over time
and ended at something that
unrecognizable or was it originally
wrong and then on page 224 it seems to
be can't understand it may cost
73,000 or it may cost
97,000 um do we have a handle on what it
might actually cost and does that
include Administration do we have an
idea of what the administration might
cost so thank
you okay on the first question uh we
we're looking at a couple of words
within the policy and what the council
or the exer services team have been
doing is is is following a process with
it year on year but the wording was
tightened up this year and that is where
this is this is this has become apparent
this situation but we'll get you a full
answer to that in jupo as soon as we can
the second one I think you're looking at
the options could you rem what the page
it was again coun 244 244 thank you let
me just go to
244 yes so we're looking at the options
that the executive are looking to
consider so it would be either applying
a flat late sorry a flat rate to each in
scope claim or undertaking an individual
assessment of each in scope claim um if
you look into the that that particular
AA 6.4.3 in that area now we we we
believe it is possible to do the second
option the individual assessments which
we believe we estimate at the moment
that that would be a cost of
97,000 and then the administration El we
will get back to you on
that coun
LE yeah
apologies your your microphone sorry
thank you um how do I word this do we
expect this to go up year on year on
year on year as a as a cost upwards as
we're having to pay out more to the you
know to these payment um and with that
on back of your last answer would it not
seem more logical to just have a flat
figure as opposed to having those
Administration costs
to to assess every single one if they're
gonna if we're going to get more and
more Clements year on Year sorry that
was a bit confusing no no no that that's
what I will try and answer as best I can
but if if we need to we can get you a
written response in in terms of this we
have assessed and we estimate the
numbers that you see in that table in
6.4.5 will be the uh the likely cohort
of people on a yearly basis so we
anticipate that we'll absorb that cost
into future years so what we're looking
to do with this proposal is for next
year carry forward the
2324 policy that we adopted in January
and came into effect on the first of
April but for the child care element of
it maintain the policy that we had in
place in
2223 so in terms of the impact our
assessment at the moment is what you
could see in in the in the table there
you're looking at around a 100 people
extra a year but what we'll be looking
to do is because of certain benefit
changes that will be happening in 2024
we're looking to have a full assessment
at that point which will give us a
chance to review but for the for the
wanting to make sure we have a clear
policy for the next year ahead we we've
gone with this Solution that's set out
in the paper
yes thank you I appreciate that just
it's just come to mind just counted that
is it the seven years we're looking at
is it statute of limitations that
allowed us to go back seven years not
the actual fact yeah we're following the
statute of limitations with that but if
people come from outside of the scope to
it so if they if they have a claim from
an early year we can look at assessments
on an individual
basis okay well with that there are no
other questions so recommendations 1 to
six are set out in this report all those
in
favor thank you very much so if we move
on to Urgent business of which I have
one piece of urgent business which is
that if this is indeed Alex's last
executive with
us so we whilst we were still in public
session we wanted to acknowledge and
thank Alex for everything he's done to
support not just this committee but
other committees across
across the council over several years
now and I believe it's at your last day
tomorrow
Alex it is indeed well enjoy your final
day with us at Trafford Council and very
best of luck for your next move um now
at this point I'm going to go and move
the exclusion resolution so if you bear
with me I will read it out if ask
members of the public um to um to if you
wouldn't mind please leave the room so
the motion is that the public be
excluded from this meeting during
consideration the remaining items on the
agenda because of the likelihood of
disclosure of exempt information which
Falls within one or more descripted
category or categories of the Local
Government Act 1972 schedule 12a as
amended by The Local Government Act and
access to information variation order
2006 and specified on the agenda item or
report related to each such item
respectively so we'll just give it a
moment thank you very
much